[Musique]
depuis le 1er janvier 2016 les deux
agences de développement économique des
départements alsaciens ont fusionné en
une seule agence la dir
l'association de développement et
d'industrialisation de la région alsace
une structure qui regroupe différents
échelons des collectivités locales à
savoir les deux départements haut-rhin
et bas-rhin et les agglomérations de
strasbourg mulhouse colmar saint louis
et haguenau objectif de l' agence qui
compte une trentaine de salariés
soutenir l'économie locale et les
territoires l'adira c'est l'outil de
développement de l'alsace
l'adira est née de la fusion des deux
agences de développement économique du
haut-rhin et du bas-rhin et c'est
vraiment un outil que nous utilisons
pour accompagner les entreprises et les
territoires la dira c'est vraiment
l'outil de la deûle à proximité dont les
entreprises ont besoin
la grande force de la dira c'est sa
souplesse et sa réactivité
l'adira est composé d'une équipe de 30
personnes et nos équipes sont
à l'ecoute des entreprises toujours
prête à les conseiller en matière de
développement et même souvent pour être
des médiateurs avec les administrations
avec lesquelles ce pas toujours facile
avec les collectivités bien entendu est
également parfois avec les avec les
banques un exemple d'entreprise suivi
par l'adira crown ces roms installés à
wittelsheim près de mulhouse ce
laboratoire de prothèses dentaires
travail avec la france entière pour
soutenir son projet de développement
l'agencé économique l'a aidé à recruter
du personnel qualifié à faciliter ses
contacts avec la chambre des métiers
pour les questions de formation mais
aussi avec les collectivités pour que le
labo puisse implantée sur un site plus
grand
l'adira est aux côtés des entreprises
pour leur faciliter la démarche de sorte
que les chefs d'entreprise puisse rester
au maximum dans ce qui est leur coeur de
métier
lorsque j'étais devenu président du car
j'ai souhaité rencontrer les chefs
d'entreprise et j'en ai rencontré une
centaine leurs témoignages étaient
éloquents il nous disait à quel point ça
pouvait être difficile pour eux
lorsqu'il s'agissait dans une démarche
de développement de trouver les bons
interlocuteurs et certains chefs
d'entreprise
excédé nous disait mais écoutez il faut
vraiment nous aider parce que nous notre
métier c'est pas ça notre métier c'est
de produire ce qui est de notre domaine
c'est pas de courir après les
administrations ou de voir quel est le
bon fonctionnaire qui apportera la bonne
signature faciliter les démarches des
entreprises un rôle indispensable dans
un contexte économique difficile
bien sûr de nombreux dispositifs
existent pour soutenir les entrepreneurs
encore faut-il que ces derniers en
connaissent l'existence ou disposent du
temps et des moyens pour les mobiliser
la dir joue ce rôle de médiateur et de
personnes ressources
une façon de soutenir la croissance des
entreprises sans pour autant engager de
fonds propres des fois une bonne écoute
et des conseils sont plus payant que des
subventions en 2016
l'adira a suivi 441 projet
d'installation d'entreprises ou de
développement d'entreprise industrielle
ou dans le tertiaire
supérieur et parmi ces 4 141 projets qui
ont été suivis 145 ont été décidées ou
réaliser ça concerne en matière
d'emplois créés ou maintenus et je parle
seulement des emplois directs 1883
emploi en 2016 et le montant des
investissements qui ont été concernés
par ces projets c'est 549 millions
d'euros
quand on a ces chiffres on voit quel est
l'enjeu qui lie à d'avoir un outil comme
la dira auprès des chefs d'entreprise
autre volet important des politiques
départementales l'habitat du logement
social à la rénovation énergétique en
passant par le soutien aux propriétaires
le conseil départemental et ses
partenaires sont présents dans nombreux
domaines d'action ici dans le quartier
de nez percés lier un quartier dit
prioritaire en pleine mutation
on trouve des logements sociaux à la
conception si original qu'on vient du
monde entier pour voir cette
expérimentation architectural et ce
qu'ils en disent le plus de bien ce sont
encore les habitants
la tranquillité on est tranquille une
fois qu'on ferme les portes coulissantes
ou d'un portable et les voitures
non franchement le fait que ça soit un
quartier prioritaire à nos envois j'ai
toujours plus ou moins habité dans s'il
est privé
j'ai même été propriétaire d'un
appartement mais ici il ya la surface il
ya le fut aussi un logement social ces
quelques logements adaptés pour les
personnes handicapées c'est un logement
qui qui pourrait être donc un exemple de
delà de ce qu'on appelle la promotion de
la mixité sociale
donc il ya énormément de personnes qui
viennent de l'extérieur qui n'habitait
même pas 1000 qui sont là donc une
mixité sociale très réussi et aussi donc
l'économie d'énergie parce que j'ai
gueulé vous que ce parc a eu deux fois
des prix d'économie d'énergie d'ailleurs
département d'après la loi matam il est
chef de file de ce qu'on appelle la
résorption de la précarité énergétique
dont on est très investie par une
politique volontariste dont la
réhabilitation énergétique on accompagne
les bailleurs sociaux on est aussi
investi auprès de l'état donc dont dans
un programme qui s'appelle habiter mieux
pour aider mais cette fois ci les
propriétaires privés à rénover leurs
propriétés de manière à ce que la
consommation d'énergie soit faible près
de six ménages sur dix sont
propriétaires de leur logement en ville
nombreux d'immeubles sont placées sous
le régime de la copropriété
pourtant certaines connaissent
les cultes et impayés charge trop lourde
pour être supporter une copropriété
défaillante peut avoir des conséquences
délétères sur l'habitat et l'ensemble
habitants nous sommes rue de sampigny
cet immeuble où la copro était en grande
difficulté a été suivie pendant deux ans
par un dispositif nommé opaque
aujourd'hui ils en sont sortis la tête
haute grâce à l'aide de la ligne et du
conseil départemental du jour pour
illustrer ce dispositif nous nous
rendons rue de saint malo
ici les copropriétaires viennent de
rentrer dans le bac c'est ce qu'on
appelle les copropriétés fragile et qui
sont suivis par un programme
opérationnel de prévention et
d'accompagnement des copropriétés qu'on
appelle la popote c'est c'est un
programme à la fois porté par l'état et
le département mise en place par l'adil
et qui aide ceux ce genre de copropriété
à aller mieux
la copropriété il fait une demande au
pac
cette demande est étudiée et quand elle
est acceptée l'adil rentrer en contact
avec les copropriétés pour voir quelles
sont vraiment les problématiques réelles
des copropriétés parce que chaque
copropriété à des problèmes spécifiques
la plupart des difficultés qui sont les
aidons à des impayés donc des
copropriétaires qui arrêtent de payer de
recharge et une fois que si un pays sont
lourds bassam et la copropriété en
difficulté au niveau des paiements de
charges ce qui fait que des fois on ça
peut aller d'une dégradation tout simple
par exemple des boîtes aux lettres
jusqu'au dégradations importantes comme
carrément l'arrêt de chauffage ainsi la
coop rue saint malo est suivi par l'adil
depuis un an elle a pu réorganiser son
fonctionnement et travaille actuellement
à dépasser ces difficultés un suivi qui
bénéficie à l'ensemble des habitants
meba que l'impact sur le territoire il
ya un impact il ya sion urbain et à ne
pas qu un impact humain les copropriétés
donc parce qu'ils sont en difficulté
c'est tout le quartier qui est en
difficulté
ainsi un dispositif ciblé c'est toute la
ville qui gagne